[Music]
welcome everyone i'm sure you're
wondering
what are you doing in the kitchen felix
well you see
it's the hottest day of the year what do
you do when it's hot
you drink yeah you drink
so therefore we have a bunch
of beverages that we're gonna try today
we as in i am because i have the best
taste
of all time that's right this is a
tasting video no one's ever done that
but i will do it better we have
cheap whiskey versus super expensive
whiskey
water from the tap versus what their
expensive was we have cheap beer
versus also cheap beer
i thought it was expensive i didn't look
at the price we're finally gonna answer
the question
once and for all does diet coke taste
better than regular coke
and also coke zero what is the
difference
can anyone know no one's ever done this
we're gonna work our way up should we
start with the water
okay i look away my assistant of video
you have to do i look away what do i do
i can see you pour them actually and
then you can mix them up right
no yeah yeah i am the producer i make a
video
okay i close my eyes sorry i'm not
closing my house
because i'm not a suit i'll have you
know i have the most
finest tongue of all time i will be able
to tell
can i look can i look i'm so excited
what i can't
all right all right
[Music]
this one smells fresher do you remember
which one is which
[Music]
okay so one of them is two pounds and
the other one is
free right it's free from the
tap water
base of smell i would say this one is
the embossing water you're not gonna
tell me okay
do i drink at the same time or okay i i
start with the cheap water because i
know it's this
this is the chi
[Music]
okay
this is the this is bus right
i told you i have exquisite they
actually it does taste better
it's more smooth you can tell they put
chemicals in it but i do like the
chemicals
what can i say can you tell the
difference
[Music]
i told you guys it's just me i know how
to do this and you saw how confident
that was right too
yeah you can't tell a difference
big brain big tongue i do have a big
tongue
all right next we do the coke
i don't know i'm gonna make that mistake
all right
do you think i cheated is that what you
think yeah i don't need to cheat
oh you forgot one of the coke so we have
curiosity cola it's about 1.6 pounds
and then we have a diet and a regular
coke which is i think it's both a pound
so is it worth paying the extra
65 so we should start between the coke
and the curiosity coke i think
and then we get into the sugar-free ones
they are close i'm confident i will nail
everything
but to be honest if i don't get the
whiskey one right i will be so
disappointed all right i can hear the
sizzling
i'm getting hints already i don't know
why i'm trying to smell the coke from
here
hey guys welcome to buzzfeed today we're
trying out coke and
regular coke yeah all right regular coke
or cure all right or fancy smancy coke
let's get it
i mean i'm just gonna straight this is
the
fancy right no this is the fancy
this is definitely fancy yeah
it's so much sweeter yeah this one
actually smells like coke this one
smells like
sorry which one is the fancy this is the
fantasy
that one of course what do you think
regular coke is fancy
smell that that is so coca-cola
that's what you get if you have that
extra money
[Music]
yeah regular coke for sure
fancy smelly coke no doubt my lock
in decision what are the results
[Music]
can
[Laughter]
what do i win prestige respect this is
the reason i wanted to do this video
because me and marcia were having
regular coke and diet coke no it was
coke zero in diet coke
and we couldn't tell the difference
right i will tell the difference
i will stake my practice
it's fine i will die in two weeks but it
will be worth it
okay i feel like we're doing important
science here
how's the pouring going over there all
right you got to get the same
measurements
all right can a swedish man tell the
difference get out of here
between coke zero diet oh god i got it
all
i gotta have zero coke
diet boom why do i only have two
that actually makes sense maybe i should
do that no no no no
no no what we learned so far it's
actually worth paying the extra money
for
if you care about the flavor you know
i've seen videos where people like
fine water tasters get epically trolled
and they're like oh you can't tell a
difference but you definitely can't tell
it can i look
you definitely can what is this oh okay
here we go
here we go here we go all right i have
them here
i have the three cokes first
this one is more bubbly don't know if
you can tell that
zoom in on that margin
well this is more bubbly yeah okay yeah
yeah yeah man this is more bubbly all
right
hmm this is not the coke
even though it's more bubbly diet has
like this weird
thickness to it
this is also a diet i don't know which
one i'll try and find the coke first
there he is more flavor more sweet this
is the cup
are we good booyah
can pewdiepie tell the difference
between coke zero
and diet coke here we freaking go guys
5 000 likes on this video and i will buy
coca-cola
okay tell you what this tastes better it
has a little drier aftertaste
it does i'm usually bad at describing
flavors but it's all coming to me
today it's got a more richness to it
i'm inclined to think that this is the
diet coke and this is the zero
yes
i mean i knew of course of course never
doubt me for a second
what did i say well this tastes better
right it's weird because i
i always buy coke zero because i'm like
it's manlier right that's their whole
marketing they try and
market it for guys but i actually do
prefer the flavor of diet coke
so like don't be fooled by marketing
guys
this is marketing this is you plebs
buying into it and here's me ascended
ascended from all flavors you just said
you also get the
manly one even though you liked it
so you were not no no no no
no what i meant was
even though i am aware of it i i still
play into it i i play into their little
game it's like when a child wants to
play with mar you're not listening to me
regular coke is better yeah but it's a
lot of sugar and it's really unhealthy
but diet coke is still unhealthy yeah i
know
i know drink water gamers
[Music]
yeah ask your questions did i say that
all right so we basically have a friend
bought this
he brought it over as a as a gift so i
assumed oh that's an expensive beer that
they got me
no it isn't i am on to you mother you
give me cheap beer
you come to my house and give me cheap
beers uh and we got call spread
the caulsberg is uh i think it's danish
yeah
which is disappointing but i'll drink it
this doesn't really make sense
i i can guarantee you i will know these
the cold sprig is up
roughly a pound and the other the other
one is 1.2 pounds
so there's no difference
negligible negligible difference yeah
neglable magical bro how do you say
ninja ball
neglige negligible
negligible
they're closed i can hear the phone
that's a sign that it's a beer i guess
okay they're quite similar in
uh in color actually zoom
hurry there wow
all right this is the cosberg right
yeah this the this smells like teenage
uh
drinking you don't know what beer you're
buying so you're just like
yeah this smells like
hey i just turned 16 and now i can buy
beer
doesn't smell anything this smells like
your uncle
when he had too much to drink and he
wants to hug you sorry uncle
they both taste bad what the [ __ ] i
haven't had beer in so long
this is actually better yeah that's much
nicer
yeah this is the this is the golden ale
and it tastes much better
sorry caulsberg you suck danish
more like ain't playing ish get out of
my way
niche all right bye denmark bye denmark
you have proven once again that you
can't do anything right
congratulations now for the final
test this is the biggest price
difference
by far i can't even find the price of
this
but it's 23 years which probably means
it ranges
between 300 to 400 pounds
i could be wrong it's probably honestly
even more because i i
can't even find it online a company sent
me this
it's a new brand bushido series by
kumu kumesen kumisen
what the hell is that what is this
whiskey
this is their first whiskey i think i
don't think this is even out
i can't find it online i am so confused
by this whiskey
oh i think i found it i found it oh my
god
so the 17 years is
400 pounds this is probably
this means this is probably like five to
six hundred
thank you for sending me jesus i don't
drink whiskey anymore
um but i still want to see if i still
got it you know i'm not gonna
i ain't gonna swallow you know what i'm
saying but damn yeah
seven hundred pounds boy did the one you
bought me was that word sensei
yeah it was wasn't it my second with
good wheeze get a wife
that gets you whiskey it's got really
good rating actually 9.2
jameson is a really nice she
this became a whiskey video
it's a nice out of all the cheap
whiskies
jameson is not bad it's good it's 20
pounds
20 pounds versus six what was it almost
yeah roughly 700. boom
you think i'm that's fine yeah i think
you're strong
thunder is about to hit at any point all
the light has left this
there's no way in hell i will mess this
up
before i felt a bit scared but no
there's no way
23 years will be very dark and it will
be
very rich in flavor it's not always
better to have more aged it's just what
you prefer but if you are a whiskey
drinker you will definitely prefer a
more rich
taste can i look might say zoom in
this is kind of crazy there's actually
very similar oh no
what if i messed this up after talking
about no
no well this is this is the bushy though
yeah don't even i don't have to smell
the jameson
because the jameson doesn't smell
anything
oh god oh
it smells so good
oh
this is so sad i don't drink anymore
damn i am smelly
it smells sweet and not
some alcohols will just hit your nose
and it's like oh
but this is just pure it's like smelling
a really nice candle
but it's the smell of pure man
your face is that did you did you smell
just the alcohol
with the smell my sister made the
weirdest face
i mean to me it doesn't smell like
anything really
yeah i can't really touch it's weird my
nose is a big plug though
okay well i passed the first test right
yeah
okay i guess i wanted to mix them up and
see if i can just go pure
flavor right because obviously it smells
better but i will
i'll clog my nose all right and then
i'll close my eyes as well
start with this
jameson oh god
maybe i shouldn't judge you soon no it's
gotta be jameson that's gotta be amazing
[Music]
yeah that's the bushido much richer
flavor
the aftertaste hits way more as well
first when they hit your tongue it's not
that much difference
but the flavor develops differently did
i get it right
no did i got it wrong no [ __ ] way i
went on this whole [ __ ] preach
are you serious i didn't mean that i
just seemed like these and then i that
was checked but these had more
are you sure yeah this is the jameson
are you kidding me 20 pound whiskey
are you serious
what this is so embarrassing look my
face is getting all red
well i guess i prefer cheap whiskey i
actually don't like the makoto that much
then
sorry makoto i'm lost for words i don't
know what to say
it does smell way nicer but the flavors
the jameson's flavor develops in your
mouth which is really weird
i wish i had more whiskey to try like
actually try
uh because i never had my culture before
well anything
can happen here on the pewdiepie channel
clearly i'm a fraud
but yeah i guess that makes it
interesting there you go out of
diet coke water and beer
it's clear that paying that little extra
is worth it
but whiskey 600 600
difference guess that's how it is
i hope you enjoyed me embarrassing
myself in front of millions of audience
but uh that's it i guess this is a good
thing for me that i don't drink whiskey
anymore so
probably for the better anyway thank you
for watching see you guys tomorrow
hey hey hey marta stop drinking it
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean